les gaz lacrymogènes lancés contre les
manifestants en réponse à des tirs de
mortiers envoyé en direction des
policiers la situation a rarement été
aussi tendue dans un rassemblement
contre le pass sanitaires hier 121 mille
personnes ont défilé dans toute la
france dont dix neuf mille à paris selon
le ministère de l'intérieur plusieurs
dizaines d'individus ont été interpellés
trois membres des forces de l'ordre ont
été blessés pour son neuvième samedi de
mobilisation le mouvement anti passe
sanitaire bas de laine à son apogée le 7
août dernier il rassemblait jusqu'à deux
cent trente sept mille personnes mais
qu'importe pour les manifestants
toujours déterminé à défendre les droits
qu'ils estiment bafouée
c'est d'abord brima thouars mon ceux qui
sont pas vaccinés c'est une crise que ce
alors les empêche d'accéder à un certain
nombre de lieux alors que macron avait
dit que les lieux de la vie courante en
aucun cas le pass and it r2 serait
demandée c'est une intrusion dans notre
intimité parce que ça veut dire
qu'effectivement en fonction du passant
on sait si on est vacciné max édition d
une copie pâle copie de ces terrains
alors que jusqu'à présent en france tout
ce qui restait de la santé devait rester
secret je suis pour cette liberté d'être
comment de pouvoir choisir ce qui est
bon pour nous je lutte depuis des années
à accompagner les gens pour chercher ce
qui est beaucoup à l'intérieur d'eux
qu'ils le trouvent tout seul on va pas
aller se faire emmener dans une décision
qui n'est pas la nôtre
dans les cortèges l'inquiétude est
palpable chez les soignants concernées
par l'obligation vaccinale qui doit
entrer en vigueur mercredi prochain pour
cette femme la mesure est très difficile
à encaisser on était à 8 à ne pas être
vaccinés ce soit je dise
et aller vite mais en fait les huit donc
moi il ya dans cette qui vont se faire
vacciner pour être pauvre pour en garder
leur emploi parce que effectivement
c'est compliqué ça le salève de moi je
vis il devait tenir un maximum et
j'espère qu'il va se passer quelque
chose pour que donc on arrive à moi j'ai
pas mis cette aventure c'est pour moi
c'est pas une vaccination va
pour l'heure le gouvernement français ne
fléchit pas face à la pression populaire
et au refus d'une partie des soignants
de se soumettre à ce passe au risque
d'être suspendu
reste à savoir si l'hémorragie
prévisible de personnel dans les
hôpitaux le fera changer d'avis